hello there reject nation happy Sunday
to you I'm Greg
I'm John we're gonna watch Ford V
Ferrari dawn of Justice today the
official trailer based on the true story
I'm looking forward to this bad boy I
actually just rewatched Logan last night
introduce you to my girlfriend bump bump
if you haven't followed us on our
patreon page yet you might want to do
that we do weekly Q&A as well as TV show
reaction stream alongs
for many shows that includes my hero
academia one punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood attack on Titan
supernatural Gotham haunting of Hill
House and Cobra Kai season two some of
those shows have reaction highlights
included those are Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural role my hero
academia an attack on Titan I'm done
talking how about you
look out there out there is the perfect
love you see it I think so
most people come it's really heavy
Carol Shelby maybe coke Ford Motor bird
Falls of this casting wanting to build
the greatest race car the world's ever
seen
to win the 24 Hours of LeMans it take Oh
take something money can't buy
well you can buy speed what in about
speed it up you a racer behind the wheel
of your car I scan miles I don't trust
him an inch we heard he's difficult
[Music]
know whatever it is she'll know trust me
you're gonna build a Tarantino movie now
Tarantino's source says hear me to three
hundred years it's 90 days
the first time Ford Motors gone to war
we know how to do more than push paper
go ahead kill go to war thank you sir
[Music]
do you think you can beat wrong
lighter and this looks crazy
and don't work for nastier
whoa
you ready I was born ready
mr. Shelby just a shot away song is
using like three Scorsese fans so it
just comes to mind that's all I think
about now I hear that that's on anyway
this movie looks pretty awesome I'm
hoping it's a hit because like I think
having the brand names excellent product
placements gonna be in this movie
having the brand names of like Ford and
Ferrari in here might be more appealing
because I feel like these like racecar
NASCAR like movies they don't really
they don't really make them a anymore
and when they come out that feel and
releasing to care and says here I mean
like the last one I really remember is
rush and I feel like maybe overseas that
might have done better than here but
this is very you know Ford it's a mare
this is car or American yeah and also I
mean like la maza is a 24 hour race in
France you know that's all about
precision and you know efficiency and so
you know this is kind of an underdog
tale for us because you know you have
all these European cars that are owning
the landscape of high performance and
then you have these guys who and like
Lee Iacocca and Carroll Shelby are like
titans of American auto history I mean
the amount of different Shelby cars and
stuff like that and I mean Iacocca
helped pioneer the Mustang in the Pinto
and like this is gonna be interesting
because not only do you have this
situation of just trying to dominate
completely out of your turf but you also
kind of will have this you know
historical look into the lives of some
of you know the American auto industry's
Titans which has got to be an extra mile
for us I would imagine as an Americans
hahahaha extra kilometer miles and
inches and feet yes absolutely I mean
even for someone like myself who isn't
well versed
and any of this information about the
history of this race I there's so much
that I think that it's such a good job
with the casting that like you I don't
even need to see a trailer you see it
telling me Matt Damon Christian Bale
just those two names alone with you
throw jumper and ball in there I'm like
okay you got my money like why did he
write that in there like I'm excited for
him especially in this because you know
it's like Christian Bale I know can
bring a ton of life to this kind of
characters has he proven that this is
gonna be the clincher I mean he will be
fat the last movie that he did and now
he's awkwardly skinny again yeah you
know he doesn't know how to you know
he's gonna get to do a great job when
he's one of those two he's like medium
waist is not gonna pan you can tell this
is already gonna be a great performance
by his stature yeah
but yeah I'm really excited for this
combination of actors and yeah for Jon
Bernthal I mean I was kind of like what
he's playing Lee Iacocca that's odd but
I like to see him get a different kind
of role because I feel like as much as I
love Jon Bernthal I'm used to see him
play certain types of tough gruff
characters and missus not even a
character that it at least by the you
know by what I know the little I know
and by the bounds of this trailer
doesn't seem like he's gonna get to that
territory so I'm excited to see his
arranged in this environment yeah and I
like the I like this riking visual flair
that you have here james mangold usually
brings that to his don't I just remember
3:10 to Yuma Christian Bale and James
Mangold worked together on that yeah but
have having him picked this like his he
has done a movie since Logan so it's
interesting that he each he had it's
been a while and he had to be really
precise and like what's gonna be my next
move and I don't want to become like the
comic book action guy but there's
something I really respect about his
films like the driving sequences here
look very stylistic I love the way how
it's all being captured in a way it
doesn't look cgi it looks all in-camera
with some real stunt performers here
like the when the cars are flipping over
and stuff or whatever you have those
tracking shots
it looks pretty intense and I think
James mangle is one of the best at and I
feel like he's underrated in this
department of being someone who can
bring action to did the dramatic films
he does
and make the action stylish intense
let's keep it very character-driven
and speaking of that there's one thing I
wish this trailer gave me a little bit
more of what I like the little nugget
where they're sitting at the diner Matt
Damon and Christian Bale or you know
Christian Bale even punches him at one
point they clearly have a thing with
their history where they had some kind
of falling out or they hadn't talked in
a while I don't exactly know what it is
but clearly they're not like Matt Damon
has to step out of his comfort zone and
approach him I wish we got a little bit
more of their chemistry together because
I like I think it's a big thing a lot of
us are gonna want to see is you know the
scenes of them interacting with one
another it was kind of surprised that
Matt Damon's getting top billing in here
just based off the trailer to it to me
it look like Christian Bale is the real
heart and star of this movie especially
starting off with him and his son
there's a several images where he's
looking over at his kid seeming like
he's trying to make his son proud in
this next venture this overcome insane
obstacle kind of adventure and putting
his life on the line well you know maybe
Damon still more of a household name
yeah well I think Carroll Shelby is dead
I mean Carroll the name Shelby is on the
sides of cars evil today so I feel like
of all the the figures in here that's
probably the biggest and to me at least
looking at what this trailer is telling
me because I don't know all the history
of this specific situation but it seems
like he is the linchpin of this
operation he is the person being
approached to figure this all out and
then you know I would imagine that
Christian Bale would be like the second
most prominent character out of this but
to me at least I kind of feel like that
makes some sense but it still looks like
the Bale performance is going to be the
Oscar contender and what's funny that
originally this was gonna start Brad
Pitt and Taemin I mean yeah Tom Cruise
which would have been powerhouse for me
to interview with a racecar driver it
would've been perfect out Chris did that
racing movie - yeah Days of Thunder
and there's also humor brought to this
this feels it's funny I have brought his
name up three times now Scorsese but
this also does feel like a kind of movie
Scorsese could have pulled off himself
it has a bounce to it has that sort of
like this is a big undertaking but it's
also gonna be fun to watch out you know
this is
the sixties right yes yes and I like
that it wasn't trying to just push a
bunch of like 60s imagery in my face -
how 60s we are yeah it still feels like
tangible for modern-day audiences this
this feels really cool man I'm really
looking forward to this to the cast
director alone practical Rex play yeah
every the one slight concern I have is
that I know there was like four or five
screenwriters credited for this that
used to concern me a lot more back then
but nowadays I see that a lot of films
can still be great even with that amount
of credited screenwriters yeah maybe
I'll watch a documentary on this event
beforehand hey listen guys four at the
sub I'd like to give a patient the day
shout-out I'm on John a handle this one
since I usually handle them to a lady
named Brianna Davidson Brianna Davidson
how's it going I know you're a gearhead
I know that you spend all of your nights
after working hard all day under the
hood of your favorite car which I'm not
going to name specifically because leafy
there it's as people could find you but
you're great and I want to see you in
this race next year because they're
still doing it and it's been a long time
since I've heard about anybody near here
you know making a splash I assume you're
from America but if you're not hey
whatever just represent us and just yeah
that's what I got to say wow that was 45
seconds and 45 second if you didn't cut
me off I could have set you up or
something very sincere for her oh but
you just decided to interrupt me with
another John improv ramble there she
only pledged to the patreon to watch
your reactions to Cobra Kai you're the
first person who's pledged occasion to
watch some ads about we got that instead
so sorry Brianna you get some weird joke
from Jon instead of that subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell if you liked this
video hit the like button are you guys
looking forward to this we'll see you
guys soon